Those who have weak presentation skills
often don't have a lack of intelligence.
It's simply a lack of awareness of
habits that they've built and why
certain things are distracting to the
audience.
In this video, I'm going to talk about
some of the biggest public speaking
mistakes and the types of personalities
that you may witness. And if you feel
seen by this video, if one of these
characteristics identifies how you are
or other people you know, I want you to
leave a comment down below and let me
know. But let's jump right into it. One
presentation style that is particularly
weak is something I like to call the
reverse teleprompter.
What is the reverse teleprompter?
Well, for many presenters, they will
have slides that are projected onto the
screen behind them.
But for some reason, many presenters,
rather than
talking to their audience, turning and
facing them, they feel the need to stand
with their back to the audience and read
whatever it is that's being projected on
the screen.
But the problem with this is that first
off, by turning your back to the
audience, that is not very engaging.
But also, if you're just reading a bunch
of text that's on a slide,
that's not engaging. That's not
interesting to watch as an audience
member.
Instead, you want to be facing your
audience. Perhaps having movement
through the crowd, making eye contact
with them.
So then if you're wondering, well, how
do I do that without forgetting what's
on the slide? Well, the first thing you
want to do is ensure that your slide
doesn't just have a bunch of words.
Ideally, it has very few words. I'm
talking two, three, four, five words or
less.
And it's mostly about visuals that
support or add to whatever it is that
you're talking about.
That imagery should simply signal to you
the general theme of what you're talking
about next. And when you build a speech
with pictures or chunks of ideas or
bullet points rather than word for word,
it allows you to be more adaptable. And
it doesn't matter if you perfectly
rehearse the same speech word for word
every single time or if it's a little
bit different as long as the general
information stays the same. One of my
favorite tricks is to have something
that in the industry they call a comfort
monitor. And in a big stage, that is a
screen below the stage that is showing
you the same slides that are being
projected. So, there's no need for you
to look backward, you can simply look
down at that comfort monitor.
But if you don't have a big stage setup
and you're in a room like this, one
thing you can do is use your laptop. So,
you'd have a laptop set up here as your
own personal comfort monitor. And that
way the laptop screen will have the same
thing as whatever's being projected and
it's connected through an HDMI. So, that
way I can quickly glance and I see the
visual and now I can speak to the
audience and I can talk to them about
whatever that visual represents. And
then when I click to the next slide, I
can move this way, take another quick
glance, and get into the part of my
presentation.
But I want you to avoid the reverse
teleprompter. Don't turn your back to
the audience
and read whatever's on the slide.
Another weak presentation style is
something I call the GPS voice. And
where people get guilty of that is when
they have notes written down and they
insist on reading the notes out word for
word verbatim and reading every single
word and sentence as it's written off of
the sheet of paper, and not ever
diverting from their notes, rarely
looking up to make eye contact with the
audience because they don't want to miss
a single word, and they want to keep
everything as it's perfectly written,
but that's boring. That's boring to
listen to. It is not engaging.
And this is something you should be
working on as a presenter is how do you
engage your audience?
And so, I would love for you to detach
from the notes.
I tried to throw that. Wasn't a great
throw. There we go. Detach from the
notes. Get rid of them.
And instead, practice your speech.
Practice enough so you know the general
themes of what you want to talk about.
And if you insist on using notes, if
you're scared to fully detach, just have
bullet point reminders. That way, as
you're presenting, you can give the
information, and then if you lose track,
you can come back to that sheet of
paper, which is now on the floor, you
can take a quick little
glance and remember what it is that
you're talking about, and now you can
move back up to the audience and present
that information, but don't be the GPS
voice that reads words off of a piece of
paper because that is not engaging. Have
you ever seen a presenter who's giving a
presentation, and they've got a lot of
energy, but they're constantly moving
throughout the room, and they're back
and forth as they're talking about
whatever it is, and maybe they're trying
to be motivational and hype up the
audience, and they're they're really
passionate about what they're talking
about?
This isn't the worst presentation style,
but it's something that I like to call
the Roomba.
The Roomba is constant movement.
Constant movement around as you're
talking, moving around the audience. And
why I say it's not the worst
presentation style because it actually
indicates a lot of confidence to be able
to move that much as you present and
constantly be energizing and it's not
the most boring thing to watch. However,
I would argue that a better presentation
style incorporates strategic movements.
So, from now from time to time pausing
in a spot when it makes sense to do so
and really allowing that thought to sink
in.
And then as you move to the next idea
moving physically to that space and
engaging this side of the room making
the eye contact and allowing that to
land.
This style is more intentional, it's
more powerful, but if you are the
person, if you're guilty of being the
room but constantly moving around, know
that that's not the worst thing, but I
do think that there's a better way that
you can present which is more purposeful
and less distracting. One of the things
that happens when we give presentations
is that our heart rate increases a lot
and we get some level of nerves and for
many people they come up to the front of
a room or a stage and they talk really
quickly because that heart rate's going
and
a lot of
filler words will
um
come into place because the heart rate's
going and we feel like we need to be
talking so quickly and any silence feels
awkward and for these types of people,
these types of presenters, it's
something I call the auctioneer.
The auctioneer is somebody who is
talking really quick because they have
all that adrenaline, all that energy and
they want to just keep going and maybe
there's the nerves and they just want to
get through this presentation as quick
as possible.
But you want to incorporate more pauses.
You want to slow down. Slow down the
pacing of the presentation
and one really clever trick to do this
is when you're practicing for a speech,
practice with an elevated heart rate.
That is going to simulate the
environment, the experience that you
feel when you actually are in front of a
room full of people.
And by doing 50 jumping jacks or running
on the treadmill for 10 minutes before
you practice a speech, you're going to
get that heart rate up. And that is
going to be very similar of what you're
feeling when you do step in front of the
audience.
So, if you've practiced with an elevated
heart rate and you've slowed down the
pacing successfully,
you're going to find on the day of your
speech, it's much easier to slow down
and allow the pauses.
Pauses let the audience think.
They allow ideas to set in.
And this comes back to the purpose of
why you're giving a presentation.
You're not standing up here to get
through it as quickly as possible.
You're standing up here to teach the
audience something.
To give them some form of value.
And strategic pacing helps you do this.
There is a common presentation type that
I like to call the wandering eyes.
And the eyes often wander two places.
They wander down or they wander up.
And when they wander up, this is often
speakers thinking. Trying to recall,
looking up in their memory, trying to
figure out the next thing that they're
going to talk about. Or they're telling
a story and they're trying to remember
the details as they're doing so.
The other alternative for wandering eyes
is that they look down.
And this might indicate a lack of
confidence.
Or there may be that thinking element as
well.
But these speakers are often trying to
muster up the courage and they're really
focused on what they're saying and maybe
they're a little bit scared of making
any form of eye contact.
But the problem with this and the
problem with that is that it's not eye
contact.
This is eye contact. And when you look
at your audience in the eyes, you create
a level of accountability.
Because it's hard as an audience member
when the speaker locks eyes with you
to then be distracted. Because you know
that speaker, especially if they're good
at continuously making eye contact with
the room,
you know that they're immersing you in
the story and you don't want to be rude
or disrespectful or on your phone or
talking to your neighbor
because you know you're being
acknowledged as an audience member.
It's far easier to ignore a speaker who
is stuck behind a lectern
or constantly looking down than it is to
ignore a speaker who is moving
throughout the room and making eye
contact.
And so if you can keep that attention
with the eye contact, there's a much
better chance that your audience is
going to remember and retain the message
you are teaching them. The final
speaking presentation style that I don't
think is very effective is something I
call the scenic route.
And this is the speaker who is talking
about an idea and then suddenly diverts
to something completely different. Who's
talking about, all right, so let's jump
into
our goals for the remainder of this
year, what we hope to accomplish as a
company. But before I do that, I
actually want to backtrack and I want to
talk about last year and some of the
things that went really well. And I
think as a company, especially John over
there, let let let's talk about John for
a second because John did something
really impressive last year and a
project that he was working on and this
took our company to the next Was it
Susie was involved in this as well.
Right. So, we'll come back to that
later. I'm going to touch on that but
for now let's get back to the original
point that I was talking about which is
the goals for next year.
And if you're trying to follow
the cadence of what's happening, it's
like you started here and you've been
taken on this crazy journey
and maybe you land at the final
destination and maybe you don't but the
speaker is constantly moving on to
different things and the challenge with
that as an audience member, it's very
hard to follow the point and understand
what it is that is the takeaway
from this presentation.
If constantly the speaker is just taking
the audience in different directions
there's less likelihood they will retain
the information.
Instead as a speaker
I would love to see some structure that
is purposeful so that the audience does
take something away. What is your most
important message that you want them to
leave with?
And you should be intentional about that
when you're presenting.
And this isn't to say you can't be
adaptable. I think adaptability is a
very important skill and something that
the best speakers are able to do.
But
for the most part a formal presentation,
a formal speech
make sure it's structured. Structured in
a way that you know your audience is
going to have some tangible takeaways. I
hope these speaking personality profile
styles were interesting to you. Do any
of you feel seen? Are any of you falling
into one of these categories? If so, let
me know in the comments. I'd be really
curious. I've been guilty
of a few of these different styles over
the years, especially the auctioneer
where I speak too quickly and a practice
presentation that takes me 10 minutes
when I practice only takes me 5 minutes
when I'm in front of a room of people.
So, this is something we have to
constantly work at and try to improve
upon. And speaking of which, my YouTube
channel, as you know, has a ton of video
content to help you become a more
confident communicator.
But if you want to take that to the next
level and you want to work with me, I
have a stand store link below with
several offerings of how I can help you
be a more confident communicator. Check
out my stand store. I also run speaker
accelerators periodically, so comment
below if that's something you might be
interested in.
Besides that, the best way you can
support me and my channel is by
subscribing to my channel.
This helps more people discover this
content and help them with one of the
most common personal fears in the world,
which is public speaking, cuz I'd love
to have many more confident
communicators out there in this world
sharing their important messages. And
check out the video that YouTube is
recommending for you right now. Thank
you for watching this one.